il paraît que la taille ça compte mais
en tout cas ce petit truc faut pas le
juger sur sa taille c'est juste ouf
c'est pas souvent qu'il ya des
accessoires qui me haïk m'a alors celui
là juste incroyable incroyable et on en
parle juste après l'intro
et salue les gens derrière l'écran je
suis super content de vous retrouver sur
cette chaîne moi c'est françois ici on
parle de vidéos de matos de captation de
tournage de tous ces trucs qui vous
permettent de faire de belles vidéos et
aujourd'hui on va s'intéresser à un
accessoire de malade ce petit machin
tout montrer dans l'intro c'est les pics
comme mike 2-2 chez picot gear et c'est
juste incroyable alors vous savez que
niveau matos info vraiment que ça
m'emballe pour que j'en parle cette
vidéo n'est pas sponsorisé picoguard m'a
envoyé le matos à ma demande pas ce que
j'avais pu tester et j'avais trouvé ça
incroyable et je voulais vraiment
pouvoir l'essayer un peu plus en
profondeur donc dans cette vidéo les
amis il n'y aura que mon avis n'ont pu
ravit pas de trucs de marque qui m'ont
dit donnez des scripts et ou non la
preuve je fais cette vidéo en totale
impro il ya un truc que j'essaie de me
rappeler souvent c'est que dans
audiovisuel à bahia audio en premier et
ça veut dire que le son c'est hyper
hyper hyper important et croyez moi pour
le son j'ai galéré un parce que faire
des images c'est une chose capter du son
c'est autre chose d'ailleurs je vous
encourage à écouter cette vidéo avec un
casque puisque j'utilise moi même le
pico mike ici juste la wii se voit pas
beaucoup hein c'est hyper discret et je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi j'ai flashé
et j'ai craqué sur ce matériel là alors
auparavant j'ai eu des rowdies wireless
go et wireless groupe doux qui sont très
bien au demeurant mais qui demande quand
même un petit peu d'installations et qui
sont pas si run and gun que ça même si
c'est très facile d'utilisation et très
simple à utiliser on peut les accrocher
comme ça à une chemise mais c'est quand
même assez gros c'est pas très
esthétique donc souvent j'utilisais un
micro cravate qui était pas forcément de
super bonne qualité parce qu' il fallait
mettre le prix dans les wireless et
ensuite mettre le prix dans le micro
cravate bref c'était quand même un petit
peu compliqué surtout que quand on doit
équiper quelqu'un avec un micro ça se
fait pas comme ça la justice bloque et
c'est fini il faut passer le micro dans
mettre dans la poche vérifier qu'on a
bien allumée l'émetteur bien allumé le
récepteur bref il ya des petites étapes
c'est rien de très compliqué mais là où
picot guérisse très très fort c'est
qu'ils ont absolument simplifier tout ça
mais de manière incroyable donc ça c'est
le micro et l'émetteur le micro il se
trouve ici sur la petite pointe qui
dépasse que vous pouvez voir ici sur mon
col et qui est vraiment de très très
bonnes qualités comparées au micro
cravate que j'ai pu avoir ça a rien à
voir il ya deux atouts majeurs et là on
n'a pas à se prendre la tête c'est que
il a un réducteur de bruit automatique
qui marche très bien ça c'était un truc
que j'avais sur mérode le bruit c'était
juste insupportable et un limiteur
intégrée c'est-à-dire que si vous parlez
un peu fort il va essayer de compenser
un petit peu ça pour ne pas faire
saturer le micro et ça ça m'arrange
aussi parce que des fois je le parle des
fois je parle beaucoup plus fort ça
sature aider quand je descends il ya du
souffle bref moi en plus j'ai l'habitude
mais quand je vais faire une interview
de quelqu'un c'est beaucoup plus facile
d'utiliser tout ça en interne
directement avec ses effets pré intégrée
sans avoir à se prendre la tête et juste
venir voir la personne qu'on va
interviewer prof lui accrocher ou juste
lui demander de l'accrocher comme ça
c'est beaucoup plus pratique est
beaucoup plus simple que d'équipés
quelqu'un d'un micro-cravate autre point
très positif c'est que ce petit pli
comac il a une autonomie tenez vous bien
non pas de 8 heures ni de 10 heures il a
une autonomie de 20 heures donc ça veut
dire que un jour où on part suivre
quelqu'un pour un reportage on lui pose
le micro le matin et le soir
techniquement on a encore de la batterie
on n'a même pas à s'occuper à se prendre
la tête de savoir si il va falloir
recharger échanger des piles ou quoi que
ce soit non il ya 20 heures d'autonomie
dans ce machin là je sais pas comment
ils ont fait je sais pas par quels
moyens magie qu'ils ont réussi mais en
tout cas ça tient 20 heures alors j'ai
pas tenté de le laisser allumé pendant
20 heures comme ça mais quand on est
allé filmer le clip de bennes sur le pic
du midi manu pentu rim avait équipé d'un
de ces micro toute la journée et ben il
est resté accroché à mon col toute la
journée on a eu du son toute la journée
donc pour une journée de shoot pour une
journée d'interviews c'est hyper
pratique on le pose au début et après on
n'a plus à se soucier juste il faut
penser à le récupérer parce qu'on a
tendance à l'oublier c'est tout petit on
n'y pense plus faut penser à le
récupérer à la fin de l'interview et
comme les choses sont bien faites et
qu'un petit bonheur n'arrive jamais seul
vous avez vu que j'ai un pic au mic ici
accroché à mon col j'en ai dans la main
je n'ai pas reçu deux packs non non j'ai
reçu un pack parce que dans un pas qu'il
y en a des tas veut dire qu'on peut
faire une interview en simultané de deux
personnes leçon wasa enregistrées sur
les deux canaux stéréo un à droite et à
gauche et après au montage on n'aura
plus qu'à soit dissocié les canaux et
faire un traitement de son indépendance
soit carrément tout mettre en mono et
avoir nos deux voix dont clairement là
aussi quand on interdit aux deux
personnes ou qu'on a deux personnes en
même temps c'est hyper pratique le
récepteur il se présente sous la forme
d'un petit boîtier sur lequel on va
pouvoir poser les micros qui sont
aimantés donc qu'ils se barrent rompt
pas il sert aussi de socle de charge
pour les micros il ya des petits
connecteurs ici qu'on voit sur le micro
on va pouvoir gérer les effets le volume
tout sur ce petit écran là ce n'est pas
le plus ergonomique de la terre neuve a
quand même le choix dans pas mal de
choses et ça serait très facilement et
surtout c'est totalement plug and play
c'est à dire que moi j'ai très peu
touché les réglages j'ai juste brancher
la sortie jack à ma caméra ou à mon
moniteur et en avant j'ai juste ploguer
on a rien à allumer vous avez ya pas de
buts on en fait là dessus dès qu'on le
sort du socle il est allumé il est prêt
à l'emploi on le pose il n'y a rien
d'autre à faire c'est juste ça qui est
incroyable au niveau de la porte et il a
annoncé pour avoir 200 m de portée alors
je n'ai pas testé les distances mais on
le capte très loin il n'y a pas de
soucis à se faire là dessus et puis
généralement quand on filme quelqu'un et
qu'on l'aimé un micro on n'est pas à un
km 1 c'est généralement n'est pas trop
loin donc a priori il n'y a pas de
raison pour que ça fonctionne pas pour
que ça décroche au niveau de la qualité
audio on est sur du 24 bits et du 48 il
reste donc plutôt cool et le dernier
truc hyper cool que je trouve sur ces
micro ça c'est un petit peu anecdotique
mais je trouve ça plutôt stylée c'est
que tenez vous bien c'est une marque
française qui fait ça c'est des petits
français qui font ces pics augure et qui
selon moi sont bien au dessus bien au
delà de tout ce qu'on ne peut voir
pulluler sur internet on est clairement
très au dessus au niveau qualité des
rhodes convoi en long en large et en
travers ce guide j'ai sorti des trucs
aussi mais c'est pareil y'a pas la
simplicité d'utilisation de ça alors par
contre c'est pas donné c'est un petit
peu plus cher que des rhodes voyant
lesbo 2 par exemple avec deux émetteurs
on est sur un prix annoncées sur le site
de 359 dollars pour la version normale
il ya une version pro aussi avec une
sortie mini xl'r mais la version normale
suffit amplement mais là où je trouve
que c'est incroyable c'est dans la
simplicité d'utilisation et dans le
temps gagné au final c'est sûr que pas
c'est un micro cravate même si ça prend
un peu de temps c'est pas grand chose là
vraiment vous dit tu avais juste ça à
clipser à un col et s'est terminée il ya
aussi le fait que c'est très fiable et
que vraiment moi j'ai une confiance
absolue donc on retire le pico mec de
son socle on la croche sur le col ou sur
la poche de veste ou ce que vous voulez
de la personne qu'on veut interviewé
donc je trouve que le prix est justifié
parce qu'on on a cette facilité
d'utilisation cette simplicité
d'utilisation qui est incroyable en plus
ça existe depuis un petit moment je suis
sur le cul de pas avoir découvert ça
avant je vous le recommande à 2000%
parce que vraiment c'est très très très
bon et d'ailleurs juste avant de mettre
le coup de blaster sur le pouce en l'air
qui situe juste en dessous cette vidéo
vous pouvez aller voir d'autres vidéos
où justement je parle de matos que
j'aime beaucoup et que je vous conseille
ardemment calaisis et moi je vous dis
rester curieux et à très bientôt pour
une prochaine vidéo show